being an adult is hard it's so easy to
get into a rut and think about you know
that ability of death let's just do it
okay
I will do something totally different
start with something like fun and like
high energy oh yeah
action hey guys nope hey this is worth
it where we tried not worth it I need
you to focus so give me man this go fund
yourself for we take people who are
unsatisfied in their day to day and set
them up with unconventional hobbies only
see if it sticks
who are you Oh I'm Kate one of your
co-hosts and that's Steven your other Co
yes where are my calls no you're not a
feminist if you're not my oh my god few
weeks ago we sent out a company-wide
email asking people if they were unhappy
with their day-to-day recreational
activity turns out a lot of people are
most people just work a lot and then go
home and watch television and then
that's it it's really a lot to like do a
new thing from those responses we see on
Bella
now think about out she believes that
fairies exist she does she used to be a
lifeguard she's a very good swimmer and
she doesn't have a whole lot of hobbies
so I matched her up with mer mating is
that a is that a recreation yeah and
then what and then we're gonna see if it
changes her life this is go fun yourself
yeah hello notoriously unsatisfied oh
there's my co-host even not cuz he's my
god no you were looking for a hobby that
was I'd love to be outdoors I'd like to
be a little creative and maybe have some
fun with it maybe add some more play
back into my life yeah I believe you
said childlike wonder childlike wonder
yes being an adult you get busy you get
tired also after work I have to go home
and feed myself it just feels like
hobbies aren't worth it after a while
yeah I'm just tired
obviously you know of all like the
conventional hobby is the cake fall it's
like the only hobby that comes to mind
give all them like stamp collecting but
there are many other very very fun ones
are there
I'm honestly a little nervous I mean
it's gonna be pretty embarrassing it
involves being completely naked
I cannot wait
[Music]
okay we're gonna reveal it now you're
gonna frickin lose your way
Oh three two welcome to your new hobby
is becoming a mermaid yeah you're gonna
get a fin and everything holy Sh there's
not real mermaid hey no they're not real
mermaid my Merman names get even pearl
and I'm being mermaid for seven year
my name is mermaid Abby and I've been a
mermaid since I was two years old I kind
of want to cry because I'm scared why
are you scared
here's the thing I am a little afraid of
people that dress up like characters
anyone who's like dressing up in an
outfit and likes being a character
because I know that it's not really them
and I'm like a little weirded out that's
my baby I respect them I respect what
they do they're very talented here's the
thing I love mermaid and you used to
swim and you're about to put on a fin
and swim with professional mermaid even
though I'm a little bit nervous I'm
gonna try to keep an open mind and just
try to have fun with it hi my name is
Merman Jax I'm a founder and a performer
for a company called dark tie production
and today we're gonna teach you how to
be a mermaid how did you get into this
it's one of the things I grew up as a
competitive swimmer
I've worked entertainment industry and I
kind of just fell into it but it's
actually really good for your body and
it's nice not just good exercise and
it's fun so not only am i learning a
hobby but a potential new career
potentially depending if that's up to
you buddy your name is Merman Jax yes so
is that your character that is the
character name yeah okay Ella will be
coming up with a character absolutely
opposed to a persona it'll be a murse
ona
[Music]
so here are some tops accessories things
to think about and your beautiful tail
that you could do use today swim tails
they provided us for you this is where
we can start thinking about if any of
these inspire you I can see like why she
picked this for me because I do like
mermaids and I talked about them a lot
and it'd be maybe more mysterious and I
go more sexy or maybe if you're shy
you're more outgoing and more friendly
are they evil marry me absolutely that
could be the thing you could look
innocent in sweet but you can actually
be a siren maybe you want to drown
people oh these are really beautiful but
let's be honest I don't have goods to
fill out those tops I'm a sporty Merman
athletic I'm an athletic evil mermaid
there it is
Wow it all happens so fast a second you
put the crown on and the last and final
step is gonna be picking what you want
your mermaid name to be I don't know I
think I need to get into my outfit I
need to practice some moves and I think
the name will become clear then first
thing I'm gonna have you do is just go
ahead and lean back okay arch your back
put your shoulders back in just sunbathe
okay and give us a smile it can be like
an evil smile right I'm gonna have you
go to your tummy oh gosh I didn't think
this would be work give me your hands
like this okay and then put your fin up
in the air yes girl
oh I'm trying to entice people over to
me yes stopping by to see how you're
feeling I'm like scared that I'm not
gonna be able to do this I got your back
mer babe very babe okay thank you you're
gonna be fantastic I don't know what to
say the puns coming out of this one are
wild how do I get into this we're going
to roll down the body of your tail okay
so that you can put your foot into your
flow okay
yeah but you're still on the fence I'm
feeling the fin imagine that
so you notice swim yes I did
lifeguarding and like some teams oh
that's really comfortable okay the
dolphin stroke or the s-curve is just
the butterfly I never really did that
one it's been up and down yes come
source I can just float you could just
float beautiful yeah that's perfect
[Music]
and I think what the fun tricks will
teach you at the tail slap pretty simple
it'll you can go really big you can go
really small you're really ready to go
we're gonna have you try a corkscrew or
barrel roll ladies and gentlemen
introducing sapphire this siren
Kate texted me and said do you want to
see Ella via mermaid and I didn't know
that she meant for real
oh yeah this is real this is a Merve
Merve Ellis day it is cool but it's not
freaking all we got some tricks
sure yeah bricks look at your trained
dolphin like a tree gasps dang mermaid
he's alone we been waiting for oh there
she goes
graceful like a mermaid that was right I
was convinced she legit looks like a
mermaid this isn't the weirdest moment
of our friendship for sure did we only
see her
yeah Ella is a mermaid I was thought of
her as like a farrier of her future it
really does feel like I'm at the query
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we learned a new hobby today we had some
ups and downs I think I always having
ink and I was nervous of like looking
dumb but once I got in that tail that
was a game-changer a second you fooled
until you literally got into character
I'm gonna be honest it was really really
fun I had to look like I having fun and
I've been really stressed out lately
working so much so you know what thank
you Kate
this was really really good oh my god
would you say it was where is it
this was definitely a unique copy but
this really reminded me to have a little
bit more fun and take stuff less
seriously I can't believe it took you
and these three mermaids to remind me of
that well change is possible kids I know
this sounds silly but I did have a great
time what a day what a whirlwind and she
having fun in like so what have we
learned from this I learned that I
should put off more sunscreen
hey unsub is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part